>> Jesse: NEW BOMBSHELL
DOCUMENTS DETAILING ALLEGED
SEXUAL ABUSE BY GHISLAINE
MAXWELL.
THE RECORDS FROM A LAWSUIT FILED
BY VIRGINIA ROBERTS FREE.
CLAIMING MAXWELL ABUSED MANY
YOUNG GIRLS.
DOCUMENTS ALSO MENTION
BILL CLINTON.
VIRGINIA SAYS SHE SAW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT ON EPSTEIN’S ISLAND
WITH MAXWELL AND "TWO YOUNG
GIRLS.
DID NOT ACCUSE HIM OF ANY WRONG
DOING.
SPOKESPERSON FOR CLINTON SAYS
IT’S A LIE AND HE’S NEVER BEEN
TO THE ISLAND.
BEFORE WE GET TO EVERYTHING WE
HAVE A FACT-CHECK FOR JUAN.
"USA TODAY," THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DEPLETES THE
FEDERAL STOCKPILE OF N95 MASKS.
IN FACT-CHECK, TRUE.
ALSO WASHINGTON STATE AND
OREGON --
>> Juan: GET OUT OF HERE.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT BILL CLINTON.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND.
YOU SAY THINGS LIKE THAT AND
THEN YOU JUST RUN ON LIKE IT’S
TRUE.
YOU DIDN’T SEE A SPIKE IN THE 14
DAYS AFTER THE PROTESTS AND
GUESS WHAT, AND GUESS WHAT.
I’M TELLING YOU, IT’S THE TRUTH,
NO SPIKE AFTER THOSE BIG
PROTESTS AND SECONDLY THERE WAS
A TREMENDOUS PREPARATION BY THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE WRONG.
BILL CLINTON ON EPSTEIN ISLAND
ALLEGEDLY BEING ACCUSED OF A
SEX TRAFFICKING VICTIM, BEING ON
EPSTEIN ISLANDS.
THE SECOND PERSON WHO FINGERED
HIM AS BEING THERE.
DOES IT CONCERN YOU?
>> Juan: CONCERNED ME?
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH JEFFREY EPSTEIN,
INCLUDING TWO PRESIDENTS.
IN THE CLINTON CASE, I JUST
RECENTLY WATCHED THE NETFLIX
DOCUMENTARY AND THEY HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO WAS THERE WHO SAYS
HE SAW CLINTON ON THAT ISLAND.
SO I THINK IT’S NOT JUST
CLINTON.
IT’S NOT JUST TRUMP.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
INCLUDING A LOT OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE PROSECUTORS
IN FLORIDA, I THINK THEY HAVE A
LOT TO ANSWER FOR.
I WILL SAY ON A POSITIVE NOTE
THAT I THINK THAT THIS DISCOVERY
PROCESS AND THE PROSECUTION IS
HOPEFULLY A STEP IN THE
DIRECTION OF GIVING THE VICTIMS
SOME SENSE OF JUSTICE.
I THINK AS WE GET INVOLVED WITH
ALL THE GOSSIP ABOUT THE
CELEBRITIES AND THE POWERFUL
ELITE MEN WHO AVOID JUSTICE, WE
SHOULDN’T LOSE FOCUS ON THESE
YOUNG WOMEN WHO WERE ABUSED.
>> Jesse: I AGREE.
THAT’S MOST IMPORTANT THING.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
REVELATIONS?
>> Greg: FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD
LIKE TO APOLOGIZE FOR SAYING
THAT DANA’S SWEATER LOOK LIKE AN
AD FOR FRUIT STRIPES GUM.
IT’S ACTUALLY THE SWEATER THAT
MARCIA BRADY WORE WHEN SHE RAN
AGAINST RED GREG BRADY FOR STUDE
BODY PRESIDENT.
WHAT’S TALK ABOUT BILL CLINTON.
LET’S STICK TO THE FACTS.
LET’S STICK TO THE FACTS, DANA
AND THE FACT IS TRUMP WAS NEVER
ON THIS ISLAND SO I DON’T KNOW
WHY JUAN KEEPS BRINGING UP
TRUMP.
THAT’S FINE.
BILL CLINTON CLAIMS HE WAS
KNOCKED ON THE ISLAND BUT HIS
IDENTIFIED AS BEING THERE AND IF
THERE’S ONE THING WE KNOW ABOUT
BILL CLINTON, HE NEVER, EVER
LIES ABOUT SEX, SO I THINK WE
CAN TRUST HIM.
IF YOU ASK BILL CLINTON, IS
BILL CLINTON GUILTY, HE’S GOING
TO SAY DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU’RE
DEFAMATION OF -- IT DEPENDS ON
WHAT YOUR DEFINITION OF "IS" IS.
>> Jesse: THAT IS SOME
AIRTIGHT LEGAL JIU-JITSU.
THIS IS THE DISCOVERY PROCESS
THAT’S JUST AT THE BEGINNING.
A LOT OF REDACTIONS IN THIS
DEPOSITION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF TODAY’S NEWS
NEWS?
>> Emily: I WOULD LIKE TO
CLARIFY FOR VIEWERS OF THIS IS
DISCOVERY AND DEPOSITIONS FROM A
2018 DEFAMATION CASE BY VIRGINIA
GIUFFRE AGAINST GHISLAINE
MAXWELL.
SHE SAID THAT GHISLAINE MAXWELL,
BY SHAMING ME IN PUBLIC YOU HAVE
DEFAMED ME SO THIS IS FROM THAT.
IT’S NOT NEW.
IT’S JUST NEW TO US.
IT’S ALSO FROM THE INVESTIGATION
BY FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS IN THE
2008 RESULTS FROM FLORIDA.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING NOW IS THE
FRUITS OF THE JUDGE IN THAT CASE
SAYING THAT IT’S PUBLIC INTEREST
TO SEE THE INFORMATION.
GHISLAINE’S TEAM TRIED TO KEEP
IT UNDER WRAPS.
THEY ALSO ARE ARGUING AND TRYING
FOR THE RELEASE, THE PUBLIC
RELEASE OF ALL THE VICTIMS NAMES
NAMES.
WHICH SHOULD SERVE NO PUBLIC
PURPOSE OTHER FOR THEM TO
CONTINUE TO CONTINUE EMBARKING
ON THIS VICTIM SHAMING ORDEAL.
A LOT OF IT IS WITH THE CURRENT
INVESTIGATION THAT RESULTED IN
CRIMINAL CHARGES WAS BASED ON.
IT’S NOT LIKE THIS IS A NEW NOW.
JUST NEW TO US BUT IT’S ALL
TROUBLING.
POWER IS MONEY.
WE SHOULD CARE REGARDLESS OF
PARTY ABOUT TAKING DOWN ANYONE
WHO PARTICIPATED IN AN INCH
INTERNATIONAL SEX TRAFFICKING
RING.
>> Jesse: DANA PERINO, LET’S
FINISH THIS SEGMENT UP.
>> Dana: FRUIT STRIPES GUM,
MARCIA BRADY EVEN BETTER.
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS FROM 2018,
IT DID GIVE US NEW INFORMATION,
OR A CONTRADICTION.
RECENTLY GHISLAINE MAXWELL SAID
IT HAD BEEN OVER A DECADE SINCE
SHE HAD SPOKEN EPSTEIN.
IN THESE DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
REVEALED, THERE WAS AN EMAIL
BETWEEN MAXWELL AND EPSTEIN FROM
2015.
THE PROSECUTORS PERHAPS KNOWING
THAT THAT WAS THERE AND THEN
GOING IN TO ARREST HER NEW THAT
THEY HAD SOMETHING SO PERHAPS
HAVING CAUGHT OR POSSIBLY IN A